hello and welcome to hot seat an
exciting collaboration between Sky News
and first news the UK's national
newspaper for young people this time
we've taken the show on the road to the
Science Museum appropriately enough
because we've got actual astronaut here
but Charles Bolden isn't just any major
Tom Dick or Harry President Obama asked
him to head up NASA he's in charge of
America's entire space program this is
who's gonna be asking the questions the
hot seat panel they've been drawn from
first newsreaders and schools across the
country number four they get stuck in Mr
Bond I'm gonna ask you to introduce
yourself thank you for coming here who
are you and why are you so important
well thank you very much I'm not very
important but my name is Charles Bolden
or Charlie Bolden is everybody calls me
I am what's called the NASA
Administrator or the administrator of
the National Aeronautics and Space
Administration headquartered in
Washington DC and it's an organization
of about seventeen eighteen thousand
people around the world and in America
we have nine NASA field centers that do
all of our work right so let's get the
Inquisition on on it you've got a
question what were you in charge of
during the four missions into space oh
when I flew my for space shuttle
missions and I'm a Space Shuttle
astronaut so you know there I tell kids
there are two generations of astronauts
today there are those who flew nothing
but the space shuttle like me a long
mission like my longest mission was nine
days today astronauts live and work in
space for six months at a time so I flew
as a pilot on my first two missions I
was the copilot the title was pilot but
I was the co-pilot and in my last two
missions I was the mission commander
which meant I was responsible for the
safety of the crew for getting the crew
trained and then the fun part was
actually landing the shuttle when we
came back to earth I mean that's TV that
on the screen on the screen and one of
my if I could see the patch that's
probably the Hubble Space Telescope
mission and and if so on that mission I
was actually oh no that's my last flight
so I was a commander there this is
who was my Mei Mei Mei assistant or
Michael palette thank you very much for
that question the next question is from
Edward Edward what do you want to ask
how do you cost time when you're in
space Oh Edward there's no question
about passing time it's how do you find
time to do things that that are fun that
you might like to do our flight schedule
is in what's called a flight plan it's
done every day and it's in 15-minute
increments and so the schedule is filled
up with things that you have to do boom
boom boom boom boom right behind the
other you're scheduled to sleep you're
scheduled to eat you're scheduled to
exercise you're even scheduled to float
into the window with a camera and take
pictures so you had to work with your
mission planners to make sure that they
gave you some time generally the time
the two times that you got to relax and
have a good time well three times when
you eat when you exercise and when you
did what we call earth observations
where you could float into the window
look out and take pictures Edward thank
you very much grace it's your question
next you had any technical difficulties
while up in space and have you ever been
scared grace we actually on my very very
very first flight we had technical
difficulty that turned out to not not be
as bad as it seemed at first
immediately on liftoff we you know you
lay on your back in a spacecraft whether
it's the Space Shuttle or saw you soar
soon and Orion that we're gonna be
flying to go to Mars
you're on your back for about two to
three hours while the ground team
processes the vehicle make sure
everything's okay
and on my very first flight aboard the
space shuttle Columbia when we finally
got through the countdown and lifted off
we were surprised for one thing because
we had been in the vehicle for previous
times and had not gone we had canceled
for one reason or another mechanical
problems weather or whatever as soon as
we lift it off within seconds we heard
the bomp bomp bomp an alarm went off and
I look down at my console and it said we
had a leak of helium from one of our
three main engines that's really really
really a bad day because helium provides
pressure for all
the seals and everything that keeps the
main engine together if you actually
have a helium failure and although all
of it leaks out the engines gonna blow
up and you're not gonna live so we knew
that I have an emergency procedure that
I I had trained on in and you know so I
was very comfortable with it and I told
the ground and my crew that I was going
to start working the emergency procedure
we got about halfway through and we
looked at our display and we saw
something really funny that said we were
making helium that's impossible and so
we call the ground again and said we
think we have a data problem it's not at
a problem with the engine at all we just
think we're getting bad data so we're
gonna undo all the corrective action we
did and just go back to normal ops and
we did and turned out after the flight
when they evaluated everything we had
just a little piece of debris that got
on one of the the little you know
computer components and it given us the
bad indication temporarily but that
sounds scary but you you also flew
combat missions how do those two types
of fear I think I never felt fear flying
in space like you did on a combat
mission when people were shooting at you
it's a little different yeah you don't
get motions you do thanks very much for
that question next question Clara at the
end there what would you like oh what's
NASA's most significant project today I
you know I have to divide it into the
various the major mission areas that we
have if you're talking about Aeronautics
the one that's most challenging to us
right now is trying to help America's
Federal Aviation Administration the FAA
the the regulating body and the United
States put the right systems onboard
autonomous vehicles drones so that we
can integrate them into our national air
transportation system so that people
like Google and Amazon and other people
can fly unmanned aerial systems into our
airspace like normal airplanes that's
that's NASA's big challenge there when
you talk about science no question it's
getting the James Webb Space Telescope
ready for its launch in 2018 James Webb
is a massive
it's gonna launch on a European
spacecraft on a European launch vehicle
out of kuru in South America and it's
going to be like 1.6 million kilometers
away from Earth and it there it's gonna
study planets and other solar systems
it's actually going to help us to look
into the atmosphere of some of the new
planets that we've been discovering that
look like earth to see if maybe there
are signs of life there and other kinds
of things if you come back to human
spaceflight in addition to working on
the International Space Station our big
goal right now is to get humans ready to
go to Mars in the 2030s so some of you
may have an opportunity to do that okay
guys ready for Mars and we've got some
questions about Mars but next question
is from Oliver yeah Oliver what do you
want ask it going to space changer in
any way I get asked a lot of times did
it change me and I would say I wasn't
changed by going into space my
perspective on on our planet on earth
changed significantly for a number of
reasons looking at Earth from the
vantage point of space is the most
absolutely breathtaking experience I had
ever had
I'd been in airplanes a lot like you
said flying around flying combat flying
other things earth is beautiful from
that perspective but from the vantage
point of Earth where you can see you
know almost a whole ball at one time you
can see the vast expanse of space
sunrises and sunsets happen boom in an
instant whereas down here on earth the
Sun rises very slowly sets very slowly
it happens in seconds in space and it's
just breathtaking
and and I became much more appreciative
of this planet on which we live I became
much more aware of the fact that as
human beings we don't get along the way
that we should because of weather their
racial differences or national
differences are sometimes very trivial
differences and I came back intensely
interested in trying to make the world a
better place a more peaceful place
Oliver thank you for that question so
next up is common do you believe in
aliens and can you tell and can you tell
us about area 51 yeah
no Carmen I there is an area 51 it is
not what many people think that I know
of I've been to the to the place that's
called that but it's a normal research
and development place I never saw any
aliens or or alien spacecraft or
anything when I was there I think
because of the secrecy of the the
Aeronautics research that goes on there
it's ripe for people to talk about
aliens being there in terms of I don't
use the term alien I use other life I do
believe that we will someday find other
forms of life or a form of life in our
in if not in our solar system in some of
the other solar systems some of the
other billions of solar systems in the
universe you know now we know things
that ten years ago we didn't know ten
years ago we didn't we didn't we hadn't
identified the more than two thousand
planets that are orbiting other Suns and
other galaxies today we know that there
are literally thousands if not millions
of other planets many of which may be
very similar to our own earth and so
some of us many of us believe that what
we're going to find one of these days is
evidence there that there is life
elsewhere in the universe
so no aliens in area 51 but of course
you would say that you would say that
yeah I'm coming thanks that question
next up is Shania Shania how soon do you
think you'll get the first man or woman
on Mars we have we have orbiters and
Landers on Mars now and we've had them
there for 40 years the United States has
almost from the very beginning of the
human spaceflight program the United
States and now working with our
international partners we're focused on
sending what we call precursors to Mars
and to other planets in the solar system
to learn as much about them for two
reasons one is to help us understand
that planet as a pair a place that we
may one day want to send humans and we
know we want humans to go to Mars so
we're trying to learn as much about it
as we can but the other reason we send
satellites and orbiters and Landers to
these places is because every time we
learn something about another planet in
our solar cell
every time we learned something about
one of its moons
every time we learned something about
asteroids and comets like you know comet
67p I can't even pronounce the name that
the european philly lander landed on
last year every time we learn things
about those bodies in the universe we
learn more about our own earth and
that's what's really really really
important well what's the date day oh
when are we gonna put humans there my
guess is what our goal is to have humans
on Mars in the 2030s so that means the
first humans will go to Mars in
hopefully in the early 2030s
they won't land they'll go and they'll
probably do an orbital mission like the
first time we went to the moon we may
put some orbiting one of the moons of
Mars and we may even decide on a second
or subsequent mission that we're ready
to land somebody on one of Mars's moons
and let them do some teller robotic
operations because we've got to get the
martian surface ready for human
habitation we're not going to send
astronauts down to the surface of Mars
to build the habitats for example the
houses where where astronauts are going
to live we're probably going to use
robots and you're going to help develop
some of those so so we'll either be in
Mars orbit we'll be back here on earth
or we may be on a moon of Mars doing all
the telematic operations running the
robots that are building the habitats
probably burrowed into the Martian
surface so we get protection from the
Martian soil from the radiation
environment out there just to pick up on
that that idea that we'll be doing it
from distance what do you make of the
notion that we could send a one-way
mission to Mars the Mars one I do what
do you make about I'm not a fan of a
one-way mission to Mars and and the
reason the biggest reason I'm not is
because today we don't know enough to be
able to sustain life on Mars our our
technical capability is not as good as
we want it to be now because we're
Americans we could be much more
demanding we need better life-support
systems we need we need a toilet it's
not going to break on the way there and
then when we get on the Martian surface
it's gonna work over and over and over
we need water recycling equipment just
like you have here in London
so that when we need water we can take
urine we can take perspiration we can
take any liquid put it into the end of
the water recycling apparatus and get
fresh drinking water out we've got to
learn how to grow plants vegetables
we've got to learn how to use microbes
when you talked about aliens Carmen I
really think that the microbes that we
discover on these other planets we are
gonna use learn how to use those
microbes to make food whether it's stuff
like steak or vegetables
it'll make concrete there are all kinds
of things that we now know we're seeing
in laboratories that we can do we know
so much more today than we knew 10 years
ago so 2030 to answer your question I
didn't realize there was toilets keeping
us from our next question is from Rosie
at the end there Rosie it looks like you
are good to every sick everything so
what are you rubbish at what am i or
what am i bad at Oh
Rosie I am so bad at so many things I I
do not speak foreign languages I I knew
a little German once I studied Latin in
school and I knew a little Latin but
I've forgotten all my foreign languages
I'm horrible at it that's not good for a
person who's you know the administrator
the head of the National Aeronautics and
Space Administration that has more than
700 partnerships with more than 120
nations it would be so impressive if I
could walk into you know into Paris and
an address my counterpart in French or
go to Africa and address my counterpart
in in one of the African nations in
Swahili or whatever the the language of
that that that country happened to be
and I don't do that very well I'm a I
love athletics I'm not a very good
athlete I love music I don't sing very
well but I love to try all the time and
I'm a I'm a mediocre kind of of a
student but i but I study all the time
and I try to learn so there's a lot that
I'm rubbish at but I would say to all of
you just because you're rubbish at
something doesn't mean you shouldn't try
to do that and that you should never
tell yourself that you can't do
something
you know say okay I know I'm rubbish at
this but I'm gonna keep working at it
until I become the best in the world
even the things that I'm rubbish at
right right all the time I'm a lousy
golfer but I play golf as much as I can
because one of these days I may learn
how to hit the ball we won't ask you for
a rendition of a tune at this point say
that was the first round we're gonna
come back now to Ahmed Ahmed your second
question is NASA doing anything to
reduce the impact of aviation pollution
on environment Oh NASA is doing an
incredible amount for example we're
working with the Federal Aviation
Administration not only in the United
States we ran a test at the Armstrong
Flight Research Center out in California
last year we had representatives from
France from Canada I think there were
some airplanes from the UK and we used
American airplanes
we had a big dc-8 that we could load for
different kinds of fuels on and we were
testing biofuels fuels that are made not
from from carbon products and then we
had a Canadian airplane a French
airplane American airplanes that that
came in and flew formation behind the
exhaust on that airplane as we change
the fuels they had very sophisticated
sensors looking at the amount the levels
of pollution coming out of the engine as
we change to different fuels we're
looking at noise pollution we had a
project that's called low boom where
we're trying to enable the the Federal
Aviation Administration to set standards
that will allow us to fly supersonic
over the ground it's illegal right now
in the United States but we think you
can design an airfoil an airplane such
that when you boom when you get a sonic
boom it doesn't go down and break
windows it kind of goes up into the
atmosphere so a lot of things to try to
increase the fuel efficiency an airplane
decrease the noise whether it's on the
helicopter rotors or an engine decrease
the pollution and make it much more
comfortable inside the airplane if
you're going on a Boeing 787 it's a
really strong airplane the the outside
of it is made of composite material it's
not metal and NASA NASA was a very big
partner with Boeing and in the design
and construction of that airplane
of course the next time you're on a
dream line I think it's good that's NASA
technology even a you know a near bus
because if you look at the wings the
very tip of the wing the winglets that's
a NASA invention and and it increases
the fuel efficiency decreases the amount
of you know air circulation and
turbulence coming out thanks very much
for the question I made Edward your
second question what do you want to
bring any three people to space who
would you bring a why Oh any three
people three my three granddaughters I'd
take them with me so they could
experience what I've experienced in
space I'd do it in a heartbeat
that's great that was a great question
grace you're a second question do you
get annoyed when people say that moon
landing was faked no I don't get annoyed
at all I mean I I understand people have
legitimate doubts and concerns I just
happen to know what I did when I flew in
space
I wasn't fortunate enough to be able to
go to the moon when I came into the
space program into the space shuttle
program in 1980 at that time I really
thought I'd fly a few flights in the
space shuttle then go back to the moon
get to land on the moon and I would
actually go to Mars that's the way we
were progressing at the time and then we
had the Challenger accident which really
set us back but I I have no doubts that
we went to the moon and I have no doubt
that we're going to Mars in your
lifetime thanks very much guys clora
your second question do you use to
convince Congress that space exploration
is worthwhile what arguments do I use
with the US Congress my friend David
Parker who's the head of the UK Space
Agency here I we talk I talk to all my
my my fellow heads of space agencies and
we compare notes every once in a while
you know he he talks about how he
approaches the Parliament we try to tell
them the benefits that come from space
exploration not just that people can go
but that when you look at the the
constellation of almost a hundred
satellites that are orbiting our earth
today just looking at earth look
the planets looking deep into the
universe particularly those that are
looking at our earth helping us
understand climate change helping us
understand what it what kinds of things
can we do to decrease the effect of
climate change on earth can we predict
bad weather much sooner you know can we
tell people one of these days when a
volcano is gonna erupt or when we're
gonna have an earthquake so that people
can evacuate areas or not build in an
area that's prone to earthquakes or
maybe a volcano and things like that
what do you thinks the biggest benefit
of space travel more knowledge about
space everything right as I said before
why don't we study other planets and
asteroids and comets because every time
we learn something that we didn't know
about that particular part of our solar
system are above our universe we learn
more about our own earth because in the
beginning we believe you know whether
you whether you believe in the Big Bang
or what we believe that all of this
started you know from some common source
and when you find a comet and you study
the water that's in that comet hopefully
it has some commonality with water on
earth we had a shock from Philly that
the European Space Agency will probably
start talking about if if you haven't
seen it already on UK news Philly found
that the water on on the you know comet
67p it's not like our water here on
earth it's heavy water so the hydrogen
in the water on the comet 67p is is from
deuterium it's it's a heavy heavier
hydrogen than the kind in our own water
so that says at least no parts of that
comet contributed to the water in the
oceans on earth that was a sort of a
disappointment thanks for that answer
Oliver your next question well is your
favorite science fiction film and
character what's my favorite science
fiction film and character who's I
actually love Sandra Bullock in gravity
because it's it may be science fiction
but it's very realistic
in many respects and I just fell in love
with her and in her character I'm also a
huge fan of the Star Wars Star Trek
I like lieutenant Uhura I love dr. Spock
so I got a bunch of them yeah you caught
it has to be Star Trek or Star Wars you
have to choose going I have to choose
one of the other I think I actually like
Star Trek better than Star Wars and the
reason was probably because in Star Trek
we don't talk as much about war and
combat and conflict and everything I
think you guys Star Trek fans for Star
Trek II four first always anyone oh okay
I can't argue with the lights what three
records were up three records would you
take into space and why Oh like like
record albums or CDs or stuff I would
probably take Handel's Messiah I love it
every bit of it
but you know all the different seasons
Christmas Easter everything the this it
tells the story of the Bible that I
study I would probably take a really
good gospel album
oh man something done by the Staple
Singers maybe or something like that and
then I'd take a sarah brightman help and
I you don't ask me which one I don't
know I'm just in love with her and and
everything she sings I'd probably take
one that's got a lot of highlights from
Andrew Lloyd Webber that has some of her
songs from Phantom and a lot of other
things but and maybe if not that I'd
take a album that's got the duets of
Sarah Brightman and Andrea Bocelli when
you're strapped in the shuttles you are
allowed to take back when I flew you
took you took we didn't have CDs so we
took little cassette tape recordings
nowadays they can take CDs or they take
their iPhones and they can upload music
all the time so they can change on the
International Space sort of Spotify
beamed up or any other streaming service
amazing they've got it easy now haven't
they really yeah so our next question is
Shania your second question what do you
think needs to be done to involve more
women in the NASA workforce Oh what do
we need to do to involve more women in
the NASA workforce my a chief scientist
dr. Ellen stofan was here in the museum
not long ago we need to have more women
like dr. Stephan or like my deputy dr.
David Newman who is an incredible
engineer was a professor at MIT until
she came to be my deputy almost three
weeks ago or we need to have more women
like the incredible astronauts in the
space program today Jeanette Epps or
like Mae Jemison or the late Sally Ride
or the late Judy Resnik we need to build
them up as heroes not a woman but here
in the UK you all need to know who Tim
Peake is because Tim Peake is a
real-life no stuff modern-day
contemporary astronaut who's going to go
and live and work on the International
Space Station by the end of this year
and so you'll have your own UK astronaut
as a as a role model and
Apple and hopefully Tim will come back
and inspire you to want to be an
astronaut or some of the other young
ladies and and you'll have women who
follow Tim Peake to become the UK's
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth
twentieth astronauts do you guys want to
be astronauts the young women on the on
the panel yeah you wanna go to space yes
okay that's great
and time for a last question sadly
running out of time but it's from Rosie
at the end there Rosie does our future
line other planets
I'm 13 so would I ever experience space
traveled Rosie are our future does lie
on other planets immediately on Mars you
know because like I said in your
lifetime we're gonna put humans on Mars
in the process of going there working
with other nations a lot of them want to
go to want to go to the moon because up
until now only the United States has
ever put anybody on the moon so in the
process of remember I told you we're
gonna live and work for about ten years
in Mont in lunar orbit what we call
cislunar space and we have a phrase for
it at NASA we call it the proving ground
we're gonna continue to develop the
technologies needed to go to Mars we're
gonna continue to understand more and
more about the human body and how it
reacts Centon in a microgravity
environment we're gonna go back to the
surface of Mars because it's less than
one gravity so it's its gravity is less
than Earth and and we will learn some
things there that will help us when we
get to Mars whose gravity is also less
than Earth's so there's gonna be I think
the future for all of you and me is
going to involve life on other planets
thank you I'm thinking oh so much this
question it's just one last thing well
we've got some children here but I mean
what message would you give to children
my message to you all is very very
simple and it's it's the way I start out
every presentation no matter what you
want to do in life three things you need
to do you need to study really hard and
people ask what should I study if I want
to be an astronaut
always always always no matter what you
want to be study as much math and
science as you can because that opens
your
- whatever you want to do even if you
think you want to be a singer or you
want to be a songwriter or you want to
be an accountant still learn as much
maths and science as you can because it
means if you later decide you want to be
an engineer or scientist you've got that
background second thing it's work really
hard and by that I mean just practice
focus when you're when you're in the
classroom pay attention to what your
teachers are doing and perhaps the most
important piece of advice would be never
ever ever be afraid of failure don't
don't be don't be shy about trying
something because you feel you're not
going to be picked somebody's going to
complain about your being there you may
be in danger
if you study really hard and you weigh
the risks you can take measures to keep
yourself you know relatively well out of
danger so I would say just don't be
afraid of failure that that's the most
important thing get out of that well big
round of applause please for mr. Charles
Boyd and thank you to the panel as well
thank you very much for coming in thank
you very much it's great it's great
being on your hot seat